blinkin Riley fritzy givin me the thumbs
up is joining us on the phone
Lincoln good morning congratulations how
did you find out Oklahoma was in the
playoffs one of our coaches at it we
were getting ready to take off a plane
to go recruiting and one of our coaches
had the show playing on his phone so
haha yeah we all kind of huddled around
the phone Watson it nervous at all yeah
a little bit yeah definitely kind of a
yeah kind of a strange nervousness you
know college football coach you wanna
you always want to be in control and
you're at that point there's something
you feel like you don't have any control
of so yeah definitely some nerves there
do you think the goal of the selection
committee is to put in the four best
teams or therefore most deserving teams
and is there a difference in your
opinion I don't think there's a
difference because I think it's uh you
know everybody you see what happens on
the last weekend and the last couple of
weeks and that's always gonna be what's
fresh and everybody's mind I get that
that has an impact and I and I do think
that what we you know I think that us
having a big total championship game the
quality team would be certainly helped
us but I do think that we forget that
it's a long season you know I mean these
games started back in September and and
it is about your complete body of work
so I do think you know that how you play
at the end is important but what you do
the rest of the season is really
important too and so I think that's a
goal woman I think together right yeah I
want to see these games this past
weekend mean something and if they don't
then we should expand a plate a teen
playoff your thoughts on the Final Four
and expanding it yeah unlike you I think
the games here at the answer certainly
mean something and and I think they you
know several of them meant a lot I think
it worked out you know it was very
positive that you had a lot of the you
know potential contenders for the last
last playoff spot or two you know
playing very very meaningful games here
at the end it doesn't mean it's always
gonna work out that way I do I mean
certainly there's gonna be some positive
so I mean of course if we were sitting
here and we were number five or number
six you'd be sick and probably be more
apt to say
of course we need eight teams but
there's always going to be somebody
right on the edge you know no matter how
many to do it I do think how you put it
together with eight teams would be
interesting you know because you got a
you can't lose the structure of the
bowls and we've had to stretch it a
little bit with this playoff to make it
work I do think a teams potentially add
some more scheduling conflicts that
would be tough would it be good for the
game as far as just having a few more
teams a few more teams I having an
opportunity I don't think I could argue
at that side of it it's not gonna
Lincoln Riley the Oklahoma head coach if
somebody had not seen Kyler Murray play
how would you describe that to that
person in you know 25 seconds he's the
best athlete on the field and the
smartest player on the field
at the same time a rare rare combination
of elite athleticism great mind for the
game incredible competitive spirit very
confident and and a great thrower
and just one of those rare combinations
athletically that you know when you
watching play just you won't you're not
going to see many like this ever is
there anything that you did is a
quarterback that you do better than
Kyler Murray no no no may have got a got
a pretty elite skill set so why I can't
still beat him in our bucket drill
though I will still take credit on that
so that's how we practice our go on
fades although he's he throw pretty nice
on the other night with a little bit of
pressure on him so but we have some fun
with that but are you the best
quarterback to ever come out of Muleshoe
high school you know I'd have a good
argument my dad and my brother died with
the it's definitely probably one of the
three and it would be it's something
that gets argued every time we'll get a
chance to get together is Mike Leach a
genius or crazy both what percentage
so Lincoln of genius and what percentage
of leech is crazy
that's that's a really tough answer
because I think it's it's the there's a
reason why he's a genius is he's a
little crazy and the reason why he's a
little crazy dangerous how much film
have you studied on Alabama a little bit
a little bit on a on AI once I got
settled into the hotel last night but
we'll try to dive into it here heavily
here in the next couple weeks but you
can you can see why it's not hard to see
when you turn on the sand why you know
why they have the the record they do the
reputation that they do yeah you might
not want to watch too much you know it's
one of those where you go be careful
what you ask for
you know maybe watch the first half
against Georgia coach that that might
make you feel a little better
yeah build the confidence a little bit
no it's gonna be good it's gonna be
thought these are these are these are
why you want to be in these games and
how to play play great teams you know
you're gonna do it we've been in several
these you're always going to play
somebody great we're certainly getting a
great challenge but then we're we can't
wait to play them do you owe it to
yourself do you have an obligation to
yourself and your wife and your family
to at least listen to other offers if
the NFL calls no no if I you know if I
didn't have a job that I thought was a
long-term deal that that we could plan
to be very successful at that is
absolutely a destination coaching job
one of the best coaching jobs in the
world regardless the sport I I would
maybe have a different answer but you
know I'm extremely fortunate that you
know I'm in a place I'm at a place like
that right now and so absolutely I don't
have that obligation favorite NFL team
growing up you know I have to say I
would have to say the Cowboys just
growing up in Texas you know that would
certainly be you know growing up a big
Troy Aikman fan you know kind of got to
grow up through some of the glory years
there so yeah I would have a hard time
saying it wasn't those guys maybe the
third best quarterback ever to come out
of Mew
shoe high school hey Lincoln
congratulations on the season and good
luck against Alabama thanks dad thanks
right now for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]